Today's lecture is a
story of Moneyball,
a book by Michael Lewis in
2003 and a movie in 2011
starring Brad Pitt.
Moneyball discusses how sports
analytics changed baseball.
Moneyball tells the
story of the Oakland A's.
The A's is a team near
San Francisco, California.
They were once a rich
team, but the team
was purchased in
1995 by owners who
enforced strict budget cuts.
Despite this, they
were improving
over the years 1997 to 2001.
In the table, you can see
that the percentage of wins
was increasing in
each and every year.
This was puzzling, and
many baseball experts
thought it was just luck.
In 2002, the A's lost
three key players.
The key question: could they
continue winning without them?
So what is the key problem?
Let us discuss the graph
on the left of the screen.
The horizontal axis
shows the average payroll
during the years 1998 to 2001.
The vertical axis shows
the average yearly wins
over the same years.
So let's look at some of
the teams in this graph.
So which one is this team?
This is a team that
won about 100 games
and spent roughly $90
million during this period.
So this is the New York Yankees.
Let's look at this team.
This team spent about $80
million and won about 90 games.
This is the Red Sox.
Where are the Oakland A's?
The A's are here.
They won about 90 games, and
they spent under $30 million.
If you compare it
with the Red Sox,
they won about the same number
of games during this period
but the Red Sox spent about
$50 million more per year than
the A's.
Clearly, rich teams like
the Yankees and the Red Sox
can afford the all-star players.
But please observe how
efficient the A's are.
As I mentioned,
they won 90 games,
and their payroll
was under $30 million
compared to the Yankees,
who spent almost three
to four times as much,
and they won, of course,
more games, but
not that much more.
So rich teams, as
I mentioned, have
three to four times the
payroll of poor teams.
Yet the A's made the
playoffs every year.
How do they do this?
And what we will see
in this lecture is
that by taking a
quantitative approach,
an analytics approach, they
were able to find undervalued
players and form teams
that were very efficient.
So the A's started
using a different method
to select players.
The traditional way of selecting
players was through scouting.
Scouts would watch high
school and college players,
and they would report
back about their skills,
especially discussing their
speed and their athletic build.
The A's, however,
selected players
based on their statistics,
not on their looks.
The following are quotes
from the book Moneyball.
"The statistics enable
you to find your way
past all sorts of sight-based
scouting prejudices."
And a direct quote
from Billy Beane,
the manager of the Oakland
A's and the architect
of this approach: "We are
not selling jeans here."
Let us contrast how
the A's selected
players versus the Yankees.
On the left, you see a
catcher, Scott Hatteberg,
that the A's selected, who would
not throw particularly well
but got on base a lot.
On the right, you
see Derek Jeter,
one of the top
players in baseball,
a consistent shortstop
and the leader
in hits and stolen bases.
Let us look into pitchers.
On the left, you
see Chad Bradford,
a pitcher for the
A's, a submariner
who used an unconventional
delivery and slow speed.
On the right, you
see Roger Clemens,
one of the best pitchers
in the game that
used conventional
delivery and fast speed.
Billy Beane was the manager
of the Oakland A's since 1997.
He played Major League Baseball,
but he was not a great player.
In fact, he sees himself as
a typical scouting error.
In the 1980s and 1990s, analysts
were hired by baseball teams,
but none of them
had enough power
to affect anything important.
As I mentioned,
Billy Beane became
the general manager of
the Oakland A's in 1997,
and he was given a
rather small budget.
He understood the
importance of analytics.
But during this period,
most general managers
knew little about statistics
and based decisions primarily
on feelings.
In contrast, Billy Beane hired
Paul DePodesta, a Harvard
graduate, as his assistant.
Furthermore, he was not afraid
to alienate scouts, managers,
and players if the quantitative
approach suggested decisions
that were different than
the scouts or the managers
or the players suggested.
An important player
in this story
is Paul DePodesta,
a Harvard graduate.
Paul spent a lot of time
looking at the data.
The analysis suggested that
some skills were undervalued
and some skills were overvalued.
The key premise of
the Oakland A's is
that if they could detect
the undervalued skills,
they could find
players at a bargain.